durch den tod von stephen hawking im
märz diesen jahres haben wir ein
brillantes genie auf der welt weniger
seine gedanken haben nicht nur
physikerinnen und physiker fasziniert
sondern auch laien die eigentlich mit
diesen themen nichts am hut hatten er
war quasi der popstar in der
wissenschaft und alles kann nicht
verraten es geht hier um schwarze löcher
und die evolution des universums
herzlich willkommen bei klick zum
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes eines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank ich
habe mich persönlich sehr gefreut dass
ihr euch in unserer whatsapp community
gerade dieses thema gewünscht hat ich
möchte das universum ganz und gar
verstehen ich möchte wissen warum es so
ist wie es ist und warum es überhaupt
existiert dieses zitat von stephen
hawking beschreibt wohl perfekt seine
ziele und ja er hat einen sehr großen
teil dazu beigetragen dass wir heute das
wissen was wir wissen
schwarze löcher schwarze löcher sind
wohl der grund warum stephen hawking
auch weit über sand forschungsbereich
hinaus bekannt wurde stellt euch mal vor
schon 1971 hat der theoretische physiker
einen theorie zum verschmelzen von zwei
schwarzen löchern aufgestellt doch erst
im jahr 2016 also 45 jahre später konnte
seine vorhersage auch im experiment
bewiesen werden oder beobachtet werden
im weltall
demnach ist die oberfläche des neuen
objektes größer als die summe der beiden
oberflächen der ausgangs objekte das
krasse daran stephen hawking beschäftigt
die sich schon mit schwarzen löchern als
es nicht einmal beobachtungsdaten dazu
gab der physiker dachte quasi nur mit
hilfe seines eigenen gehirns papier und
bleistift darauf herum und kam so zu der
erkenntnis dass schwarze löcher
keineswegs eine einbahnstraße sind
sondern laut den naturgesetzen
verdampfen müssen
zu der sogenannten hawking strahlung
komme ich gleich noch viel ausführlicher
jedenfalls folgt aus dieser überlegung
auch das so genannte informations
paradoxon der fachbegriff für den
folgenden widerspruch geht es nach
einsteins relativitätstheorie müsste
materie bei überschreitendes
ereignishorizont eines schwarzen loches
verschwinden und zwar gemeinsam
der von der materie transportierten
informationen die dann für immer
verloren wäre die quantenmechanik
dagegen sieht das anders demnach kann
eine information nicht vernichtet werden
dazu schreibt rocking im jahr 2013
die information geht nicht verloren sie
wird nur nicht in brauchbarer weise
zurückerstattet es ist so als würden sie
eine enzyklopädie verbrennen streng
genommen
die dänen ihr enthaltene information
nicht verloren wenn sie allen raus und
alle asche sorgfältig aufheben aber sie
lässt sich sehr schwer lesen
noch im oktober dieses jahres war eine
arbeit von hawking zu schwarzen löchern
veröffentlicht worden die er wohl kurz
vor seinem tod erstellt hatte wir hatten
ja hier bei kings um science-fiction
über berichtet und auch hier
beschäftigte er sich mit dem sogenannten
informations paradoxon hawking hat sich
sein ganzes leben lang mit schwarzen
löchern beschäftigt seiner meinung nach
haben schwarze löcher nicht nur masse
ladung und einen drehimpuls sondern auch
temperatur
somit müssen sie wärme in den weltraum
abgeben und am ende ganz verdampfen so
hocking wo geht also die information hin
wenn ein schwarzes loch verdampft und
mit ihm alle objekte die es eingesaugt
hat in seiner letzten arbeit hat hawking
dafür einen lösungsansatz präsentiert
der erklären könnte wie zumindest ein
teil der informationen eben nicht
verloren geht sondern erhalten bleibt im
mittelpunkt dieser überlegung steht die
entropie somit quasi der grad der
unordnung beschrieben wird eine
ausprägung von informationen welt also
ein objekt in einem schwarzen loch
verschwindet steigt sowohl seine
temperatur als auch die entropie diese
könnte gegebenenfalls mit photonen also
lichtteilchen erfasst werden die den
ereignishorizont des schwarzen loches
umkreisen und selber mit informationen
dann durch diese photonen erfasst würde
leider ist damit das informations
paradoxe noch nicht gelöst denn immer
noch nicht ist klar ob die entropie
alles widerspiegelt was in einem
schwarzen loch landet zweitens der
urknall das universum hat einen anfang
hawking schloss seine doktorarbeit im
jahr 1966 ab und schon zu dieser zeit
waren die aufmerksamkeit seiner ganzen
kollegen und kolleginnen gewiss der
damals hatte er einzig und allein aus
der einsteins relativitätstheorie
abgeleitet dass das universum einen
anfang haben muss an der urknalltheorie
hatte der großteil der fachwelt vorher
gezweifelt mittlerweile ist die big bang
theory längst etabliert hawking hatte
die erkenntnis dass die zeit erst mit
dem urknall in die welt gekommen sein
konnte und die evolution des weltalls
war wohl neben den schwarzen löchern
hawkings große leidenschaft unter
anderem erkannte er dass sich die
singularität im urknall und in einem
schwarzen loch gleichen seiner ansicht
nach kann das gesamte universum aus
einer singularität entstanden sein
ein großer stern kann demnach aber auch
zu einer singularität zusammenstürzen
das gibt die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie jedoch nicht her
denn danach müsste das universum
eigentlich einen anfang haben doch auch
dafür hatte auch gegen dann eine lösung
parat eine art imaginäre zeit die ihren
anfang am südpol hat somit kann der
anfang des universums auf den südpol
einer kugel fläche gelegt werden die
singularität wird damit vermieden denn
das universum ist damit in sich
geschlossen wie eben eine kugel fläche
die auch keinen brand hat diese
überlegung von hawking wird oft als die
kein rand hypothese bezeichnet und ist
seiner ansicht nach der schlüssel zur
schöpfung zur antwort auf die frage
warum wir hier sind
auf den punkt gebracht wäre der urteil
gar kein urteil sondern eben der südpol
unseres universums womit es eben den
urknall nicht als anfang gebe sondern
eher ein punkt auf einer kugel wäre das
universum wäre dann auch in der zeit
dimension eine kugel und es gebe eben
keinen anfang und kein ende
und das ist wirklich verrückt ich denke
wir gerne mal so mein leben es ist eine
einheit und nichts davon ist vorbei das
ist dann letztlich sogar nur eine
illusion
drittens die hawking strahlung seine
erkenntnisse zu schwarzen löchern und
der sogenannten hawking strahlung sind
vielleicht der paukenschlag überhaupt
des brillanten genies hawking nämlich
erkannte dass sie oft als staubsauger
bezeichneten schwarzen löcher nicht nur
materie verschlucken bis dahin nahmen
die fachwelt an das schwarzen löchern
nichts einfach gar nichts entkommen kann
doch der physiker zeigte dass die
strahlung aussenden und letztendlich
langsam verdampfen bis sie dann irgendwo
verschwunden sind heißt also schwarze
löcher halten nicht bis in alle ewigkeit
und das waren tatsächlich nicht nur
überraschende sondern sogar
revolutionäre erkenntnisse diese
strahlung wurde dann einige zeit später
als hawking strahlung bekannt ja damals
auch ein ausführliches video gemacht der
vierziger ging sogar davon aus dass es
irgendwann einmal ein zeitalter geben
wird in dem im weltall keine schwarzen
löcher mehr existieren was jedenfalls
besonders faszinierend an seiner
überlegung zu hocken stangen ist dass
sie durch die anwendung der
quantenmechanik erst möglich wird
schwarze löcher dagegen entstehen durch
überlegungen der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie der größte traum der
physik ist es diese beiden theorien
zusammenzubringen eine große
herausforderung in diesem zusammenhang
experimentell konnte die hawking
strahlung bisher noch nicht nachgewiesen
werden
dies gestaltet sich als schwierig weil
sich schwarze löcher zum einen in
astronomischen distanzen finden und die
hawking strahlung wohl eine sehr geringe
intensität hat zudem könnten andere
strahlungs effekte in der umgebung des
lochs diesen effekt überwiegen so ist
der nachweis der hawking strahlung bei
echten schwarzen löchern wohl fast
unmöglich doch moderne
teilchenbeschleuniger könnten das
unmögliche möglich machen wenn es
gelingt schwarze löcher künstlich im
labor herzustellen wo das wäre wirklich
revolutionär aber keine angst jedes
objekt ist quasi ein schwarzes loch
es hat einen schwarz schild radius in
dessen bereich alles in sich
zusammenfällt allerdings ist er dann
meistens so klein oder immer so klein
dass eben kein schwarzes loch entsteht
bei der erde zum beispiel 8,8 mm um bei
der sonne drei kilometer dementsprechend
sind eben auch schwarze mini löcher
vollkommen ungefährlich aber es wäre der
hammer wenn ein solches loch erzeugt
werden könnte und dann die hawking
strahlung gemessen werden könnte wenn es
soweit ist werden wir natürlich darüber
berichten wenn ihr dieses video dann
nicht und auch alle anderen videos
verpassen wollt dann abonniert klicks um
auch auf englisch denn auch da gibt es
immer wieder videopremieren einfach
dafür hier draufklicken und direkt hier
geht es auch weiter mit mccandless into
galaxies ja bis bald hoffentlich auch
auf dem englischen kanal ziel stay tuned
unbedingt drauf drücken